after returning to the modern era and
the cold war call of duty is headed back
to world war ii with sledgehammer's next
entry in the series call of duty
vanguard is both a broader and a more
specific look at the conflict
sledgehammer is telling a story that
will take you across several fronts and
show you four different perspectives
culminating in the creation of the first
special forces a development that will
change how wars are waged forever
gamespot got an early hands-off look at
vanguard which gave us a whole lot of
information about the game note that we
couldn't capture video from the event so
a lot of what you're seeing here is
footage from call of duty world war ii
if you want more call of duty coverage
be sure to hit like and subscribe
to start with sledgehammer studios head
aaron halon acknowledged the stories of
employee harassment and discrimination
from the state of california's recent
lawsuit against activision blizzard head
to gamespot.com for full coverage about
the lawsuit how activision has responded
what employees have said about working
there and all the latest news about the
situation
the presentation then dug into
vanguard's campaign which focuses on the
birth of special forces which means
taking on the role of four specialized
allied soldiers as they come together to
form a team on the multiplayer side the
focus is on the feeling of what it's
like to play as those special forces
soldiers in all combat scenarios
it sounds very much like a combination
of 2019's call of duty modern warfare
reboot and sledgehammer's call of duty
world war ii from 2017. in fact
sledgehammer says vanguard uses an
upgraded version of the modern warfare
engine you play as elite soldiers but
they're not yet the tier 1 operators of
modern warfare as sledgehammer described
it the down the barrel experience of
fighting in vanguard will have you
feeling like a hammer rather than modern
warfare's scalpel a lot of that comes
down to having the powerful automatic
weapons of world war ii at your disposal
while it seems we'll have opportunities
for stealth gameplay at times a lot of
vanguard is going to be about hitting
the enemy hard and fast to overwhelm
them don't expect the house clearing
moments of modern warfare vanguard seems
like it'll be less controlled and a
little more chaotic
vanguard's single player campaign
follows four characters each from a
different allied nation on their journey
to become the first special forces team
sledgehammer says the game is rooted in
history but not beholden to history so
this is a fictionalized story based on
some real people and events it's also
not linked to the story of call of duty
world war ii each of the main characters
is inspired by actual soldiers who
fought for the allies and the battles
they took part in sledgehammer says that
while working with historians on the
game the team focused on tide turning
battles and moments where individuals or
groups of soldiers had a major effect on
the war effort we saw a bit of the
campaign in action in which players took
on the role of sergeant arthur kingsley
the eventual leader of your special
forces team kingsley is a paratrooper in
the british sixth airborne division who
takes part in operation tonga in which
paratroopers jumped into normandy the
night before the allied invasion on
d-day his jump goes very badly as german
anti-aircraft guns pummel the british
planes and his shoot catches fire
kingsley manages to pull his reserve
chute just as he lands and nearly drowns
as he crashes into a pond losing his
rifle from there kingsley has to avoid
german patrols sneaking through the
darkened french countryside we saw the
usual call of duty blending of hands-off
cinematics and gameplay with kingsley
eventually finding a weapon and fighting
off german soldiers in a farmhouse the
whole portion highlighted the chaotic
high-stakes feel we can expect from
vanguard's missions there will be the
usual blend of stealth and tactical play
but these are turning points in the war
and sledgehammer wants to get across the
stakes and fear as well as the feeling
that you can also smash through the
enemy forces
sledgehammer said it's going for a
filmic blockbuster feel with vanguard
and the operation tonga level certainly
gave that impression the entire level
was intense with kingsley spending most
of it on the run hiding from enemies and
with very little ammo sledgehammer also
said that you'll have regenerating
health as you play health packs are gone
this time it seems likely we can expect
a similar approach from the rest of the
campaign you'll play as each member of
the team as they fight through battles
on different fronts of the war before
they finally come together as american
fighter pilot jack wade you'll fly in
the battle of midway before being shot
down over the solomon islands and
joining the 93rd infantry division
paulina petrova is a russian sniper who
you'll play during the battle of
stalingrad she's not just a deadly
sharpshooter but also an inspiration to
the russian people finally australian
lucas riggs fights in the north african
battle of el alamine disrupting the
enemy supply lines to help stop the
german tank division fighting there
eventually the team will come together
for a mission in berlin near the end of
the war
the allies have picked up intelligence
about something called operation phoenix
the team led by kingsley are sent to
infiltrate berlin find out what
operation phoenix is and try to stop it
sledgehammer also gave us some quick
facts about vanguard's multiplayer
offerings which sound like they'll
include some significant shifts from
other call of duty games the biggest new
item is champion hill mode which
sledgehammer described as being a bit of
a mix of battle royale and modern
warfare's gunfight mode eight teams face
off to be the last team standing on a
single map vanguard will also include
maps and game modes that will change the
combat pacing of your battles some modes
will be considered tactical which slows
down the speed of encounters requiring
you to be more methodical and careful
and where every bullet matters
on the other hand blitz games will pack
as many players into a map as it can
reasonably withstand creating a faster
more chaotic game that's high risk high
reward there will also be standard game
types which sound like they'll have a
more classic call of duty feel
firing up multiplayer from quick play
you might play through all three
experiences back to back you'll also be
able to set filters so you just get the
types of matches that you want vanguard
will launch with 20 multiplayer maps 16
of which will be six v6 maps with the
other four being two v2 maps expect
these maps to feel different from other
call of duty games going back to the
idea that you're a hammer and not a
scalpel maps will feature a lot more
destructibility than call of duty games
in the past where you won't just have
the ability to shoot other players
through certain pieces of cover or walls
but you'll actually be able to destroy
walls to create new lines of sight or
pathways it's not quite the level of
destructibility of battlefield games but
more like rainbow six siege where you
can alter certain places on the map to
create temporary advantages
expect multiplayer matches to shift as
they get more and more destroyed we
didn't get too much else in the way of
details about multiplayer but we do know
that elements like the gunsmith are
coming back along with additional
customizations like ballistics and ammo
types sledgehammer said it will reveal
more details in an upcoming multiplayer
showcase
in addition to the usual campaign and
multiplayer vanguard will also have its
own zombies mode which is being
developed by treyarch
the mode will act as a prequel to the
zombies mode in black ops cold war so
it'll operate in the same universe with
more zombie's lore and connections to
the story expect some alterations and
improvements to the core gameplay though
finally vanguard is also getting a new
warzone map developed by raven software
it uses the same tech as the rest of
vanguard so the guns and mechanics will
feel the same when switching between
vanguard's other modes and its warzone
map all of warzone's different
iterations will be connected through a
new metaverse sledgehammer says and
raven is also working on new anti-cheap
measures to improve the game
expect the usual live game features to
kick off when vanguard launches as well
sledgehammer says there's a huge
calendar of free seasonal content
planned and while it didn't give any
specifics it sounds like you can expect
elements of the campaign narrative to
carry forward with seasonal gameplay
just like in other recent call of duty
games as well as new multiplayer
offerings the last thing we know is the
release date november 5th 2021
we will have plenty more coverage of
call of duty vanguard ahead of its
release so be sure to stay tuned to
gamespot
[Music]
you